[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is where it happens--
a skillful touch, a thoughtful
look, the morning rush,
an evening stroll, out in
the cold but always warm.
We are the front line.
Hear us.
See how we work together.
With Chromebooks
in our hands, we'll
be faster, more connected,
and better informed.
We'll keep going the
distance, and we'll always
have your back.
Because we are the front line.
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURA JONES: Hello, and
welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars daily.
My name is Laura Jones, and
I'm from the Chrome Enterprise
team.
And today we'll be
talking about how
to turn your frontline
workers into cloud workers.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
So first, you might
be wondering, well,
what's a cloud worker?
So let's start out there.
Now, it's fair to say that
the cloud has fundamentally
changed the way that
many of us interact
with technology in
our personal lives.
We're used to a world where,
at a click of a button,
I can stream music or movies
to any device that I want.
I can order up a car to
meet me exactly where I am
and take me exactly
where I'm going.
It's technology
that works instantly
that's easy to use
that's seamless
across all of my devices.
And all of this interaction
with cloud technology
in our personal lives has raised
the expectations for the way
that technology
should work at work.
And there's many
employees today that
are using cloud technology
to do the vast majority
of their work, and they're
preferring that as well.
And we call these
workers cloud workers.
And they make up today about
25% of the employee population,
but we think that that's
just going to grow over time.
These cloud workers value speed,
convenience, collaboration,
and fluidity of work.
They want to be able to work
wherever, whenever they like.
Now, when you think
about a cloud worker,
you might think, OK, I
know who these people are.
They work in technology.
They're probably in marketing.
But the fact is
that cloud workers
span beyond traditional
role segments.
It's not about where you
work, but about how you work.
And we think that one
segment of the workforce that
could benefit the most
from cloud technology,
and perhaps could be the easiest
to move to cloud technology,
are frontline workers.
So let's talk about what we mean
when we say frontline workers.
These are the workers
that are building
the products that people,
customers interact with.
They're the people
in front of customers
who are impacting the
brand every single day,
and they're often deskless.
They're cashiers, nurses,
call center agents,
people on the
manufacturing line.
80% of the global
workforce is deskless,
and many of these deskless
workers are frontline workers.
Frontline workers build
up a wealth of knowledge
from the routine and
essential services
that they provide every day.
And this is knowledge that is
critical for a headquarters,
for a brand to be
able to tap into.
They're the backbone
of the company,
and they're the
face of the company.
Whether building the product or
directly in front of customers,
frontline workers
have a direct impact
on the customer
experience, which
impacts the bottom line too.
Think about the last time
you had an interaction
with a brand.
You were probably interacting
with a frontline worker.
You were at a restaurant
and had great service.
You were speaking to
a call center agent
and had maybe bad service.
How did that impact the way that
you thought about that brand?
The reality is that
it probably had
a lot more impact than
the advertisements
that we see every day.
And this brand
interaction is extremely
important to the business.
According to HBR, customers who
have positive experiences spend
140% more with the brand
than those who don't.
But even though they have
this outsized impact,
frontline workers are
often left behind,
and their full potential remains
largely untapped because of it.
According to another HBR
survey, only 12% of leaders
believe their
organizations invest
sufficiently enough in
the frontline managers who
are the people
training and making
sure that the frontline
workers, that the servers,
that the call center agents
are able to do their jobs well.
And frontline workers
who have to deal
with a lot of
communication don't
feel like they have the
tools to be able to manage
that communication.
And even more, 75%
of frontline workers
feel their employers
aren't telling them
enough about the changes
in policies and goals.
So think about that.
If these are the people that are
meant to represent your brand,
and they don't know enough about
what's going on at the company
and what the
company's mission is,
they can't do their
jobs as effectively
as they should be able to be.
We've also seen that
they're being left behind
by technology.
We did a survey at Google where
we asked information workers
and frontline workers
whether the technology
in their workplace has changed
over the past five years.
And what we found is
that information workers,
70% of them said yes.
And I think that's
pretty standard.
But when we asked frontline
workers, only 50% of them
said yes.
Think about how much technology
has changed over the past five
years.
And only one in two
frontline workers
are benefiting from
the technology advances
that information
workers have seen.
So the disengagement that
comes because frontline workers
aren't getting
enough investment,
aren't getting the
right technology--
it has a high
price for companies
and for the economy as a whole.
According to a McKinsey
study, frontline workers
are more pessimistic
than their managers
about leadership and motivation.
And we've also seen,
just as a standard,
that store employees
turnover was 65%, much higher
than the industry average.
That turnover, coupled with
potentially lost revenue
because a frontline worker isn't
as informed about something
that they need to be--
that all can create
disengaged employees
that cost the US economy
between $483 to $605 billion
in lost productivity every year.
So it's a real problem.
So we've talked about
the outsized impact
that frontline workers have,
and we've talked about the fact
that they might not be
getting enough investment.
So it's clear to us at Google
that digitally empowered
frontline workers
aren't a luxury,
but they're a necessity in
today's fast-paced moving
digital economy.
And we think that cloud
can unlock the potential
of this workforce.
On one hand, it creates a
better employee experience
by giving employees more
information that they
need to do their
job, by ensuring
that they're engaged
and connected
with the organization.
And those happy
employees are then
able to provide better customer
service and experience.
Along with that,
cloud technology
can be used for things
like personalization
or better processes that make
it smoother for the customer
to interact with your brand--
things like self-service,
for instance.
And cloud has stronger
security and increased value.
Chrome Enterprise, the
OS devices and browser,
is the right choice
for your organization
when thinking about
how to put the power
of the cloud in the hands
of your frontline workers.
It has benefits for both
workers and for your business.
For frontline workers, it can
increase access to information.
You can put applications
through the Google Play Store
into the hands of your
frontline workers.
They can access applications
via the web browser.
And if you use VDI for both
desktop and app virtualization,
that works with Chrome
devices as well.
Chrome devices are
fast and familiar.
One of the things that
we hear a lot when
talking to our customers is
that frontline workers might not
be as digitally savvy as
an information worker,
and so they need
something that's really
easy to onboard for employees.
Also, they're onboarding a
lot of employees at a time,
so they need something,
again, that's easy to use.
Chrome OS is built on
a browser foundation,
and people know how
to use a browser.
So it's just quick and
instant for them to use.
And there's a versatility
of devices for any use case
that you need them for.
For your business, Chrome
Enterprise is secure by design.
And I'll talk more
about that in a bit.
It's also easy to
share and manage.
And the big benefit here
is frontline workers
are in a bunch of
different locations,
spread out, not
always at headquarters
and able to interact with IT.
And so when IT can remotely
manage, they can scale.
And we've heard from
a lot of our customers
that they can go from 200
to 600 employees over time
while maintaining the
same set of IT resources
because it's that
easy to manage.
And Chrome Enterprise
is a smart investment.
So let's talk about the benefits
to the frontline workers first.
First of all, it helps them
get their valuable time back.
Now, we've all been there where
we're waiting for our device
to boot, or we're waiting
for an update to happen.
And that's lost
productivity time.
Chromebooks boot in
six seconds or less.
I just open up my laptop, and
I can get to work right away.
This is one of, for me
personally, the best
things about Chromebooks.
And updates happen
in the background,
so I don't have to sit there
waiting for 30 minutes,
waiting for that
progress bar to go around
for my update to start for
me to get back to work.
It just happens seamlessly.
I don't even know
what's happening,
but I know my device is secure.
And cloud-based profiles
enable a consistent experience
across any device.
So I can be a mobile worker
walking the hospital floor,
and I can log in to
any device that's
near me with my cloud profile,
and I get the experience
that I need.
Or if I've lost my device
or my device is broken,
I just pick up another
Chromebook, sign in,
and I'm ready to get working.
And with on-device AI and ML,
I can also find my applications
much faster.
That way, I have the
information in front of me
that I need to do my job.
And Chrome devices have a
wide variety of form factors
and come from all
the major OEMs.
So there's tablets
for a store associate
who's roaming the floors
and helping out customers.
There is clam shells
and convertible devices
for employees who need a
device in a stationary location
or mobile workers.
And there's, of course,
desktops for those employees
who are at a desk all day
like a call center employee.
And all Chrome devices come
with a standard 10-plus hours
of battery life,
which means I can
be working all day long without
having to charge my device.
And we have form factors that
are more rugged and tough
for those environments that
need a solution like that.
So let's talk about the
security of Chrome Enterprise.
This is an area that
our engineering team
spent a lot of time focused on.
From the firmware all the
way through the applications,
Chromebooks, Chrome
OS, and Chrome browser
are secure by design with
multiple layers of security.
This way, employees
fall to harmful attacks
like malware attacks.
And if one does prevail,
it prevents that
from spreading across the OS
with things like sandboxing
and side isolation.
And with verified
boot, I'm ensured
that a tampered OS never boots
up on my operating system.
And if you didn't know, there
are actually two operating
systems on a Chrome device.
So when I boot up my machine,
if one has been tampered with,
it will seamlessly boot up the
other OS in the background.
And this is great because we
hear a lot from IT departments
that they want to make
sure frontline workers have
a really secure device.
Because first of all,
their hourly employees,
there is turnover.
But also, frontline workers
are working with a lot
of customer and patient data.
And it's really important
that that data remain secure
and that these employees
don't fall for harmful attacks
like phishing or malware.
And then, of course, there's
regular and controlled updates
that happen in the background.
Every six weeks, you can push
an update to your employees.
You don't have to
worry about them
accepting the update or not.
It just happens seamlessly
in the background.
And with the Chrome
Enterprise license,
you can manage your
entire fleet of devices.
There's 200-plus user
and device policies
so you can make sure that your
employees only have access
to the applications
that they need,
that it's preloaded
with the information
that you wanted to have.
You could even do things like
lock down the on-device drive
so that employees can't
save any information
to the actual device, and
it's secure in the cloud.
And the Chrome
Enterprise license
allows you to work with
your current infrastructure,
so integrating with things
like your Enterprise Mobility
Management solution
or the identity
that you choose to have.
And of course, it comes
with 24/7 support.
One of the areas
in IT management
that Google and our customers
have seen lots of benefits for
are in significant deployment
and support savings.
So Google has a mixed ecosystem.
We use Windows devices, MacOS,
and of course, Chrome OS.
And what our internal
teams have seen
is that a Chrome OS
device takes 33 minutes
to deploy compared to two hours
and 21 minutes with a Windows
device.
Think about all the devices
that you have to deploy over
a period of time.
That's significant savings
for the IT department.
And then when we look
at support savings,
there's only 19
tickets for Chrome OS
for every 1,000 active devices
compared to 95 for Windows.
So less things are going
wrong on the Chrome OS
devices that the IT
department has to handle.
The other really special
thing about Chrome OS
is the unparalleled
multi-user experience.
So this means a few things.
One-- I could securely
share devices between users
through encrypted
cloud profiles.
If I'm using ephemeral
mode, as soon
as an employee signs out of the
device, the device is wiped,
and it's then ready for the
next employee to sign into.
And this is really important
when you think about the fact
that frontline workers
could be sharing one device,
up to 10 employees
using that device.
And you don't have to
worry about anything
being left on the device when
the next person signs in.
It also means that
I can flexibly
configure my devices
for whatever use case
that I need in an instant.
So I could take this
Chromebook today,
and use it for
customer self-service,
and manage Guest Mode, and I
could deploy it in a few hours
to an information worker
who needs to use it
for their regular business.
And I can sign in
to any Chromebook
to pick up where I've left off.
So I talked about this before,
but if my device were to break,
I could just pick up
another Chromebook,
sign in, use it instantly,
and be productive.
Now, all of this-- the
productivity from the end user,
the decreased IT resources
needed, as well as
the hardware and
software cost avoidance--
that adds up to big
benefits for the business.
We conducted a total economic
impact study with Forester.
And according to the
composite organization
using shared Chromebook
devices, they
realized, over three
years, $1.5 million
in hardware and software
cost avoidance, $3.5 million
in employee productivity
gains, and a 75% improvement
in IT productivity.
Now, depending on
your use case, you
might also want to add
on a productivity suite.
And Chromebook works with
anything that you need it to.
But we recommend,
of course, G Suite
to help with collaboration
and communication.
Using Drive and Docs,
Sheets, and Slides,
you can share information
to your employees,
and they can easily
consume it in the cloud.
And they can also
share information back.
And it's really important to
have that two-way communication
between frontline
workers and HQ,
because again, they have
that wealth of information
and knowledge about
what's going on.
And then with things like Gmail,
Hangouts, and the new product
currents, you can also
make sure that you're
having that two-way
communication
and keeping employees engaged.
With the Google
Admin console, you
can manage both Chromebooks and
G Suite from the same place.
And G Suite is built with
powerful Google search and AI
so it's faster to
get things done.
The solution that brings
this all together,
one of the new solutions that
we introduced a few months ago
with our partners, is Grab
and Go with Chrome Enterprise.
Now, we develop this here at
Google as a loaner program.
So if my device breaks
down, I go to a shelf
stacked with Chromebooks.
I pick up a Chromebook.
I sign in.
I use it for the day.
No interaction with IT needed.
And then when I'm
done with it, I simply
mark that I'm returning it, sign
out, put it back on the shelf,
and then it's ready for
the next person to pick up.
Again, no IT involvement needed.
This means that I have
24 access to that,
and that it saves IT a
bunch of time and expense.
So this is used for
a loaner program,
but you can imagine using
it for a shift worker.
A call center employee comes in.
They pick up the
device they need.
When they're done,
the next shift starts,
and they could pick
up those same devices.
That helps you have
less devices on hand.
It also saves IT money and time
in getting those shift workers
the devices that they need.
So I've talked a lot
about Chrome Enterprise
and the benefits that it
has for frontline workers.
Now I want to go through some
actual use cases and customers
that we have seen
implement Chrome devices
to their frontline workers.
So let's start with the first
one of digitizing, engagement,
and training.
I think we all know how
important training is,
but it can be difficult when you
have a decentralized employee
base.
So think about people
who are working
in a retail environment,
for instance.
They don't have
access to come in
to HQ when they need training.
So you need to be able to deploy
training to these employees.
And a lot of employees don't
have one-to-one devices to just
be able to do that
training on their own time.
So you can either have
a pool of devices--
and we see a lot of customers
actually start with Chromebooks
here because it's an isolated
environment that they
can put these devices in without
a lot of change management.
We also see retail and
food service companies
have these devices in the
back office which then allows
employees to go to
the back of the office
when they have a chance,
get their training,
fill out their HR paperwork, do
other things along those lines
on those back office devices.
And one of those customers
is Panda Express.
Panda Express recently adopted
Chromebooks in its back office
so that its employees
could get training
to make your favorites, like
orange chicken and Kung Pao
chicken, so that they have
a consistent experience
across every single
one of their locations.
And these employees can
use it for training.
They can also use
the same device
to log in to their
Office 365 environment
if they need to do more
productivity-oriented tasks.
And they work with their
partner, their channel partner,
to create an application
that allows employees
to use these training
modules offline because some
of the locations have Wi-Fi that
isn't as consistent as others.
Another area that we've
seen a lot of adoption
is improving
back-of-house processes.
So think about manufacturers
on the line who
need the latest
product specs or people
who are in a warehouse
who are shipping
and need that
information about what
they need to be shipping really
instantly and seamlessly.
A lot of this is
actually today being
done on paper-based processes.
And that's just simply
insecure, and it also
causes things to be out of date.
There's only so many times you
can update a paper before you
give it to a shift worker.
And things could even
change during a shift.
So one of our
customers is Sanmina.
They're a global manufacturing
and supply chain company.
They manufacture a variety
of products, including
intensive care unit monitors.
And it's really
important for them
to have version control for
these types of ICU monitors
because they're critical.
Right?
So they moved all 75
of their factories
from a paper base manufacturing
to Chrome devices.
And now I'm going
to show you a video
of how Sanmina has done this.
CARL DUCKETT: Sanmina
is a world-class global
manufacturing and
supply chain company.
You may never have heard of
us, but the products we build
are extremely high reliability.
Whether it's a warfighter
or it's someone
in ICU in the hospital,
people's lives depend on them.
If something happens,
we need to be
able to understand how
that product was built.
20 years ago, you had a lot
of information, but none of it
was useful.
It was sorting through file
cabinets and folders and paper.
One of the biggest
transformations for us
on our manufacturing
floor was going
from paper-based manufacturing
process instructions
to a cloud-based system.
The importance of
document control
is huge when you build
high reliability product.
Today we have
everything stored safely
and smartly in the cloud.
So Chrome is a cloud-first
operating system
that powers our operations.
A Chrome-based
system is much better
than where we were previously.
The hardware is cheaper, and
also, the cost of data security
is a piece that you
can't even quantify.
Within Sanmina, we've
got 75 factories.
It's hard to walk around
a factory in Thailand
and a factory in
Ireland in the same day.
With Chrome OS and 42Q
being closely integrated
throughout our factories,
we're able to do real time data
analytics anywhere in the world.
They really are the backbone
of everything we do at Sanmina.
And Chrome OS is the operating
system that it runs on.
So Chrome is empowering
everyone to be a cloud worker.
With the help of
Chrome OS, we're
a lot more efficient
and a lot more secure
than we were before.
When you see the
products we build
that really do change
people's lives,
it makes it emotional
and personal.
LAURA JONES: So let's talk
about customer contact centers.
These are highly important to
having great customer service.
If you think about when
you most recently called up
a contact center,
you were probably
frustrated about some things.
That's what led
you to call them.
But someone who's on
the other line that's
really knowledgeable
that can get
you your information
straight away,
that could probably
change the way that you
think about that
incident and help
save the day for that brand.
So it's important
that contact centers
have technology that's really
easy to use, that is simple
and that's fast.
And we've seen a
lot of companies
adopt Chrome Enterprise
for their contact centers
for these reasons.
One of our customers,
Mercado Libre,
they're a company that
operates online marketplaces.
They were struggling
with the Windows machines
that they were using because
of the long boot times.
In fact, sometimes they
would take up to five minutes
to boot a device.
And in an hourly
shift environment,
five minutes is just
five minutes too long.
So Mercado Libre, with the
help of our partner Neverware,
updated their existing
hardware with Chrome OS.
And now, with the
six-second boot time,
they're able to save
215 minutes per shift
across all of their employees.
It's a lot of time saved.
It also helps the employees
start their day off better,
perhaps be happier.
In addition to that, because
of the cloud-native nature
of the operating
system, Mercado Libre
can have their associates
work from anywhere.
So in case of a
disaster, or in case
they lose power at their
contact center headquarters,
these associates are able
to work from home using
Chrome operating system because
they can just sign in and get
their entire profile there
for them on whatever device
that they have, whatever Chrome
device that they have on hand.
The next area that
I want to talk about
is front-of-house workers.
So these are the workers that
are in front of your customers.
They're the ones
helping out picking
a dress for a special
occasion or helping
them sign up for a bank
account in this instance.
And front-of-house workers,
they need technology
at their fingertips right away
to be able to help customers.
We did a survey
with Forrester that
found one of the top pain
points for frontline workers
with technology
is that they have
to leave their customers in
the middle of an interaction
to go find information.
It just makes for a bad
experience for everyone.
So you can put
technology into the hands
of your front-of-house
workers, give them
laptops or tablets on the floor,
but you can also help them out
by offloading some of
that work onto customers
with customer self-service.
And in fact, a lot
of customers like
serving themselves before they
need to talk to an associate.
Charles Schwab did this.
When they were introducing
their new Schwab Intelligent
Portfolios, they wanted
to introduce a customer
self-service solution
into their branches that
was easy to use for someone
of any technical ability, that
was easy to manage.
Because they have lots
of different branches,
and they didn't want
their associates
to have to troubleshoot.
And so they introduced Chrome
devices as this solution.
Now when someone
walks into a branch
and wants to learn more
about these portfolios,
an associate can hand
them a Chromebook.
They can explore the
offerings, and then they
can do the application
straight from there.
This helps cut down this
time for the associate,
and it also has helped to
eliminate some common errors
that might happen if you're
doing two-way communication
to fill out an application.
The last one that I want
to talk to you about today
is information on the go.
Now, think about field
workers or mobile workers
who need to be able to tap into
a device wherever they are.
They need a reliable device.
They need a device that can
give them the information they
need very quickly.
And nowhere else is this
more apparent than for EMTs.
And Middlesex Hospital,
one of our customers,
they were having trouble
with the devices that they
were using for their EMTs.
They were breaking down a lot.
They weren't available
in those crucial seconds
that EMTs need to
get information.
And so they adopted
Chrome devices.
And now I'm going to show
you a video about how
Middlesex has helped their EMT
workers with Chrome devices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN CONNELLY: We respond
to approximately 10,000
9-1-1 calls a year.
Instead of having to wait
until the call is complete,
we can get started
immediately with a Chromebook.
JIM SANTACROCE: The
technology for us
has to be patient-centric.
To operate in the
Chrome environment
with no learning curve has
been a huge advantage for us.
MICHAEL ROMATZICK: Healthcare IT
is undergoing a bit of a shift
for the last 15, 20 years.
No longer do you
have a $3,000 PC that
was for a specific use case.
Our on-call doctors, our EMS,
they are roaming workers.
The ability to easily hand off
one device to multiple people
without leaving a footprint
of what they were working on
or where they'd been, it allows
a great deal of flexibility.
JIM SANTACROCE: What we're
doing is bringing the emergency
department to the patient, so
our technology is critical.
We've had zero failures
with the Chromebooks.
When they open, they're on,
and they're ready to go.
And they definitely give us
a better level of confidence
when we're out in the field.
MICHAEL ROMATZICK:
Google Cloud and Chrome
provides us an opportunity to
bring a modern, secure platform
into the health care arena.
And the Chrome
integration with Citrix
allows us to access our
legacy applications.
What Google is allowing
us to do is put
the focus back on our patients.
LAURA JONES: So if you like
what you heard today and want
to learn more about how
Chrome Enterprise can help
your frontline workers and
hear about more case studies,
please visit our website site
at g.co/chrome/frontlineworkers.
We have a white paper there
that you can read more about,
and you can also get in touch
with us for more information.
So please stay tuned
for a live Q&A.
We'll be back in
less than a minute.
OK.
And we're back with
frequently asked questions.
So the first one-- can we
invest in Chrome hardware
while still maintaining
our Office 365 environment?
The answer is yes, you can.
And I gave you the example
about Panda Express that's
using Office 365 with
their Chrome devices
for their frontline workers.
The thing that I would
recommend is figure out
how your employees
are using Office 365.
They can access the
Android application,
and they can access
the web version.
If that's enough-- and it
should be enough for almost all
frontline workers, especially--
then it should be
as easy as just
letting them access via the
Android app or the web app.
No special updates needed there.
So yes, you can use Office
365 on a Chromebook.
The second question--
is there any way
to restrict access so that
employees only have access
to certain applications?
Yes, you can.
So there are a few things
to talk about here.
One is manage Google Play Store.
So you can whitelist and
blacklist applications
so that employees
only have access
to certain applications
in Google Play,
and then you can also blacklist
so that they can't download.
But often, what our
customers are doing
is going even further than that.
And you can very
easily administer
policies that lock a device
down to just a few applications.
And we see this happening a lot.
So if you, for instance,
are in a warehouse--
we have a customer,
Stitch Fix, who does this.
They have certain applications
that employees on the warehouse
use for their day-to-day
work, and then
they also have applications
for things like time sheets
or any of the HR administration
that they need to do as well.
What are our options
to have users sign in
without an identity
for temporary access?
Well, I'm glad you asked.
We have Manage Guest Session.
And this allows
people to sign in
without using identity while
still giving you full access
to manage the device, the
applications, and the browser.
So we have our customers who
are doing a lot of self-service
with their own customers
using Manage Guest Session.
And you can also use it in
those sorts of environments
where maybe you have one
device that's there for people
to do more administration
tasks where they
don't need to use an identity.
You can just set the device
up with Manage Guest Session
through the Google
Admin Console.
How do customers currently
deal with offline capabilities
or limited Wi-Fi situations?
So we'll first start with one
thing, which is to myth bust
the fact that Chromebooks
don't work offline.
Chromebooks do work offline.
I use mine often
while I'm traveling
on airplanes when I don't
have access to great Wi-Fi.
You can use GSuite,
Gmail offline,
and there's also certain
applications that work offline.
Some of our customers
do a couple of things.
One, there are Chrome devices
that are enabled with LTE,
so that is an option.
You could use a Wi-Fi hotspot.
So that's something
that Middlesex Hospital
does for their EMTs.
And then the
customer example that
I gave with Panda Express--
they're using one
of their partners
to create an application
for their training
that works offline.
And this way, they don't
have the dependency on Wi-Fi.
And then the last question--
MacOS and Windows already
provide regular updates.
So what's the difference
with Chrome OS?
So Chrome OS not only
provides regular updates,
but one it does it
in the background.
So this way, you don't have
to worry about your employees
accepting those updates.
They just happen, so you
don't have that delay.
You don't have to
worry about the fact
that someone has just been
delinquent on updating
their device.
And they also happen every
six weeks consistently.
You can choose whether or not
you want to implement those
every six weeks.
But if you do, that
helps to mitigate
any issues a lot quicker.
So that's all the
questions that we have.
Thank you for tuning in.
Please visit Cloud OnAir
to discover more content
from Google Cloud experts.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]